Film Courage: What notes do you
give screenwriters the most?
Writer/Instructor and Script Consultant Shannan
E. Johnson (The Professional Pen): Let's see,
there's so many. I give some of the same notes so
much that I have I now have a template of notes
right so that you know back in the day I used to
have to rewrite the same note over and over and
over but now I kind of have a template of some of
the notices I give the most often but I think the
largest one is lack of a goal or a problem to
solve and lack of an inciting incident because
the inciting incident causes the goal or the
problem to solve so usually if there is no goal
or no problem it's because there was nothing that
caused it and so I end up giving those two things
or I'll say your inciting incident is very clear
this is what it is and anytime I do it I follow
it up with this is what it is that way the writer
can go that's not what it is and they can realize
oh well it's not as clear as you thought it was
right but just because you have a clear inciting
incident doesn't mean you now have a clear goal or
a clear problem and so that's the nuts and bolts
of what your screenplay is so if your inciting
incident isn't clear and if the goal that they're
trying to achieve or problem they're trying to
solve isn't clear then now I'm going to be lost in
the sauce of the rest of your screenplay because
I don't know what I'm tracking so kind of like an
essay right right you have your the first page of
your of your essay you have to have your thesis
statement usually in your first paragraph because
the thesis statement is telling us this is what my
hypothesis is this is what I'm going to try to
prove to you and then all of the the following
paragraphs have the evidence of the thing that
you hypothesized or the thing that you're trying
to prove so now I can read it and go okay this
connects back to that this connects back to that
because I know what I'm tracking the same thing is
true in a screenplay if you haven't given me that
inciting incident and that goal or that problem
then I don't have a thesis statement so I don't
know what I'm looking for so you can have a whole
lot of Adventure a whole lot of fun a whole lot
of action a whole lot of whatever but what does
it all mean if I don't know what I'm supposed to
be tracking if I don't know if this is even if
if their story should even be taking them down
that path because you didn't make it very clear
for me what they were seeking in the first place
how many tries does it take for most New Riders
then to once you give them those notes correct
it several drafts yes but I think it depends on
the person some people are great at revising at
addressing notes right that's another skill set
that writers need to have and not all writers have
it just because you are revising doesn't mean
you're solving the problem just because you're
changing your script and writing another draft
does not mean that you're fixing what the issue
was right so a you have to get a note that informs
you of what the issue is right so we were kind of
talking about development executives earlier right
and most development executives are not writers
it's not an expectation for them to be writers and
there isn't a training program in story you know
for them to be executives like we talked about
they're coming in with their Rolodex of who they
know their job is to connect people to each other
their job is branding and marketing and all these
things and they're also giving you notes on your
on your drafts but they might not necessarily
know the same language that you know as a writer
because they didn't study screenwriting right so
sometimes writers can be given a note that they
simply just don't understand because they're not
speaking the same language as the person who's
giving the note so it's harder for me to then say
well that person doesn't know how to address notes
when the note itself might have been the problem
right if the note is saying hey we have a problem
here but it can't tell the writer why there's a
problem then the writer is left to not only figure
out the why but also then figure throughout the
how to fix it right and so if they don't know what
the actual problem is then they're not going to be
able to address it and Executives usually try to
solve the problem for writers and I spend a lot of
my time when I'm doing my training with Executives
I train them in story because I know again most of
them are not writers they didn't go to film school
they don't have to go to film school there's no
training in that so I will work with executives
so they can learn the act structure for whatever
it is their brand is doing try to teach them
the jargon so that they can more effectively
communicate with their writers right but let's
say they don't have that information so executives
spend a lot of their times going well what if
we did this or what if we did that but again if
you don't know story structure then your what if
might be exacerbating the problem right and now
the writer has been given examples of what they
can do and they may think the executive is telling
me that's what I have to do and so then they put
into the script with the executive suggested and
the problem is still there but neither of
them knows why the problem is still there
because maybe neither of them know structure very
well you know what I mean so if the note is clear
and then the writer can't address it then it might
be that they just aren't very good at addressing
notes they might be great at giving you a good
first draft second draft a good foundation right
but when it comes to really making things clear
that just might not be their skill set there are
other writers who are great at that who are not
going to do the first draft they're not going to
do the second draft they're going to be able to
come in and they're going to address those notes
right and so I've dealt with some new writers
who after one or two times but talking to me
they're able to address notes right but that's
also because I'm speaking their language I'm
talking to them in the language that they speak
about writing and then I have other clients
where they can talk to me 10 times and they still
won't be able to address the note but that's just
because they don't have the skill set to address
the note it's a totally different skill and it's
something that I'm gonna figure out how to teach
so I've been giving more kind of workshops and
talks on how to address notes because if you want
to be a professional writer and you want to not be
Rewritten all the time and you want to be able to
stay with your project from the beginning to the
end you have to be able to address notes and I
just think we don't talk about that often enough
what if they understand story and you're speaking
their language but they feel that their version is
right yeah so this is where you hope that there
is an opportunity for open dialogue right on one
side of it it doesn't matter if you think it's
right now that it's been purchased by the studio
or network it's theirs not yours so it doesn't
matter that you think it's right you know what I
mean they could be giving you a note because it's
coming from the very top and this is what it has
to be you don't have to like it your job is to do
it because at this point they're paying you for
it that's literally your job now with that being
said depending upon like we said earlier you got
to read the room understand the environment know
if this is one of those cases where it's like you
know what let me just address the note or if it's
maybe I can talk to them about it then I would say
the same thing needs to be true you as a writer
need to understand how to express yourself well
enough to make them understand why you're right
and it's not by saying I'm right you have to be
able to show them in the script if we make this
change it's going to have this ripple effect which
is going to cause this is that what you would like
the executive who probably didn't understand you
know may not have understand understood the note
that they were giving was going to make those
changes might go oh no actually that's not what
I want at all but you wouldn't have known if you
didn't ask and it's about how you ask right versus
no we're not going to change that it's blah blah
blah but being able to explain to them well for
example if the executive says I don't like this
moment where the daughter curses her mom out
I don't like that at all and they decide to
change it to the daughter coming in and saying
something nice right that changes everything
because if I say something negative to someone
we're going to take that negative tension into
the next scene if I come in and I say something
positive to someone we're going to take that
positive tension into the next thing right and if
the point was the daughter curses out the mother
in this scene because eventually they're going to
get into an actual fist fight if I change this and
make it positive how do we get them there so then
the question becomes do you not want them to have
a negative relationship do you not want them to
get to this fight because the writer is going
to be thinking I still got to get them there and
will it now feel disingenuous if this moment is
gone how do we now show the trajectory of them
going from one end of the extreme to the other
right whereas what the executive was really just
trying to say is I didn't like the word choice
in how she was talking to her mother I still want
it to be negative I just don't want her to curse
but if they can't be that specific then now the
writer is going oh they don't want any negativity
at all and now we got to change everything
and blah blah blah but being able to have that
conversation is going to be helpful and it's
another thing that I tell you know executives
about the notes process right like a lot of places
and everybody does it differently because like we
say you got to read the room you gotta know what
it is everybody does it differently but a lot of
places will give the notes in the moment to the
writer so the executives have gotten together
hopefully with the studio as well maybe they did
maybe they didn't and they will get their notes
together then they'll get on the phone with
the with the writer and they'll read out the
notes or discuss the notes with the writer now the
writer has received all of this what is considered
negative information because we're sensitive right
so even even if they said one time really good job
but the rest of it was change change change change
change change change change all we're hearing is
bad bad I'm a bad person I'm a bad person then at
the end of the phone call they'll go okay do you
got it you good and the writer is gonna lie and
go yeah yeah everything's good and then they get
off the phone and now they're freaking out right
whereas if you're able to send those notes a day
or two a day or two ahead of time then the writer
has an opportunity to cry scream whatever it is
going to do digest the notes and and then have
questions prepared for things that they don't
understand but we usually don't get to get to
the question part because we spent the whole
notes call you know reading out the notes well
they're writers they know how to read they can
read the notes they don't need you to read them to
them what what they need is a discussion what they
need is to be able to say so when you said you
don't want the cursing did you mean you don't want
a negative relationship or did you just mean that
you want her to use different words now the writer
has had time to digest and come back and ask the
question and now the executive can go oh yeah yeah
it's just about the words right but you have to
have you have to have time in those calls to be
able to do that and you usually don't if you're
spending the entire call giving the notes instead
of being able to actually discuss them so that
the writer feels good about what they understand
you're asking them for which gets you closer to
them actually being able to address the note then
if they can't address the note now you might be
able to say oh this writer doesn't address no as
well so should should a writer maybe and I don't
know if this is overstepping their bounds but ask
hey is there any way I could just get the notes
and email to me first and then we can do the call
so then they can compose themselves and be just in
a better frame of mind yes they can ask and they
can also say no right but I think I think you can
ask if you know that it's better for your process
and really I think it's probably better for most
people's process right like you don't want to be
on the spot because also depending upon what
your relationship is with these executives or
what their expectations are they want you to pitch
out your solves right then so they're on the phone
going this doesn't work this doesn't work this
doesn't work okay so what are your ideas and all
you're thinking is I'm just now taking in the
fact that it doesn't work I don't have an idea
yet I don't know how to fix it yet I need to
go think about it but now you're on the spot
and you're trying to come up with these answers
right whereas if you had the 48 Hours like I'll
even say don't send it you don't want to send it
out a week before because you don't want a writer
sitting in it right because in our sensitivity we
will then try to address all those notes ourselves
and then come back and go well we fixed it all
right it's like no we still need to talk about it
to make sure we're on the same page right but I do
think if you if you can give that writer 48 hours
to read it digest it and come with their questions
then that's helpful some people just don't do it
that way because of what I said before they don't
want the writers freaking out so they don't want
to send it to them ahead of time they would rather
be on the phone and allow the writer to hear the
tone of their voice and you know all of that so
they know this is not that big of a note and this
is a larger note and we don't want you to freak
out about this and blah blah blah they they'd
rather be able to kind of control that but no
matter what when a writer receives a note they're
feeling negative stuff you know that's just what
it is good critique bad critique whatever it is
we're feeling critiqued you know what I mean and
so if you give us that time to kind of sit with it
on our own then we can come back and have more of
a conversation so we can get to where we need to
get so I say yeah ask doesn't mean that you'll get
it but definitely ask why do screenwriters think
that executives are the enemy because they are
the ones that are given the notes you know what I
mean and you know kind of like I said any feedback
can just be taken as I'm bad I'm wrong right so I
spend time you know working with screenwriters for
them to understand that the executives have a job
their job is to give you feedback that is not
a reflection of who you are as an individual
right they have a job to do which is this is our
brand this is your story and we need those things
to be this so that means I gotta give you the
notes that are going to get it there also what
I have learned even with working with professional
writers is just because you're in this room as a
professional writer doesn't mean what you write is
perfect you know what I mean there are going to be
notes there are things that need to be changed
you can look at it as look at all of the rest
of the people who are part of my brainstorming
committee right you're not on your own we're so
used to doing this by ourselves in our rooms in
our you know in front of our computers that we
think that we're the only people who know our
characters we're the only people who can you
know decide which which way things are going to go
but really there are so many other people who are
part of this process who can make your project
fantastic so be welcoming to the rest of the
people in your brain trust you know what I mean
and so but I can understand them looking at them
as the enemy because they are the ones who are
going to come slice and dice that thing they are
the ones who are going to come and possibly take
it away from you you know give you your check take
it away from you and then go off and make it what
they want to be by the time it gets on screen that
can be for the better or for the worse so I can
understand how you could put them in that in that
enemy box but if you more so consider them your
sidekick you know what I mean like they're the
person who are here to kind of help you if nothing
else help you make your money right even if the
baby doesn't become the thing you want it to be
they are here to help you get to the end of your
contract so that you can fulfill it and get your
check they are on your team at least they should
be right and you never know what personality
is going to be like and people have different
personalities and it might not be that easy of a
of a process but at the end of the day they are
here to help you they want you to win if you don't
win they don't win right so so they really do want
you to win even if it feels like they're always
you know the person who's bearing the bad news.